[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique sur l'antenne de France 24 je
suis ravi de vous retrouver voici les
titres ce soir à la Une le Tchad
toujours sous couvre-feu après la
répression des manifestants par les
forces de sécurité c'était jeudi dernier
un jeudi noir avec officiellement une
cinquantaine de morts le président m'a
mati Driss Déby a pris la parole ce soir
correspondance Mamadou Jim tebaye et
analyse avec mon invité en plateau et
j'ai nommé Roland Marshall à tout de
suite à la Une également trouver des
solutions aux problèmes sécurité que
connaissent de nombreux pays africains
c'est l'objectif notamment du Forum
international de Dakar la 8e édition
s'est ouverte ce lundi l'occasion vous
l'entendrez pour Macky Sall de prôner
une réforme du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU et puis deux attaques meurtrières
en trois jours et au moins 13 morts les
djihadistes imposent de nouveau leur
violence au Tchad ne manquez pas notre
reportage à la frontière malienne ou les
déplacer ont toujours la peur au ventre
de rentrer chez eux
c'était donc ça première prise de parole
depuis les événements de jeudi dernier
le président Hammamet Idriss Déby a donc
pris la parole nous rejoindrons notre
correspondant un peu plus tard dans
cette édition bonsoir Roland Marchal
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes chercheur associé à Sciences
Po on l'a entendu nous tout à l'heure en
rédaction pas d'appel au calme a priori
de la part du Président c'est une
surprise selon vous oui
j'avoue que je ne comprends pas très
bien la logique de de cette situation
puisque ce qui est important aujourd'hui
c'est essayer de ressouder une
population qui a montré des signes de
division très fortes au-delà de la
violence de ces manifestations et
surtout essayer de rassurer de de d'être
transparent sur ce qui s'est passé de
façon à ce que les gens puissent
regarder l'avenir de façon un peu plus
sereine c'est le sentiment qu'on a
depuis quelques jours en écoutant les
papiers à la radio à la à la télé d'une
fracture sans précédent sur place je ne
dirais pas c'est quand même si je
n'avais souvent entendu de mes
interlocuteurs tchadiens je crois que
c'est il y a eu des sentiments de ce
type qui ont été qui ont existé en 1993
au moment d'une autre conférence
nationale organisée par le père et puis
on se répète finalement ce n'est pas du
tout le même contexte et il y a eu il y
a eu des incidents très sérieux et donc
c'est cette ce schisme à l'intérieur de
la population et également il faut le
rappeler dans les années 2000 donc ce
qui quand même devrait inciter les les
dirigeants tchadiens à faire preuve
d'une qui sont en partie de l'opposition
donc qui ont vécu des deux côtés cette
période difficile à faire preuve d'un
plus grand calme et je dirais de aussi
de savoir jouer la le l'apaisement en
montrant une volonté de négocier alors
que là on est vraiment dans des un
discours de tentative de coup d'État de
subversion il est très difficile vu de
d'y croire quand bien même on montre à
la télévision des des dizaines de
machettes stockées dans des endroits si
vous voulez il y a un problème de
crédibilité d'abord et puis ensuite
c'est pas avec des machettes qu'on
renversera le pouvoir à ne jamais
n'arrive pas le dire on n'a pas besoin
d'être un expert militaire pour ça
Roland Marchal y a-t-il aujourd'hui des
motifs d'espoir quand on sait que le
dialogue national a été boycotté par les
deux parties d'opposition les deux
principaux des parties depuis suspendues
est-ce que ça signifie que la solution
politique a été tout simplement enterrée
je crois qu'il faut il faut compter sur
les ressources de l'Afrique et de la
région avant toute chose c'est à dire
pas simplement regarder la France ou
l'Union européenne voir les États-Unis
qui ont finalement pris position et ce
sont à l'armée de la violence excessive
qui a été utilisée je crois que aussi
dans la région au Niger et ailleurs un
certain nombre de responsables
politiques de et de sages d'anciens
peuvent jouer un rôle dans une dans une
la médiation dans la reprise de
discussion il faut absolument éviter une
rupture totale qui est accroîtrait les
divisions internes et qui effectivement
remettrai sur
comme scénario probable une extension
une approfondissement de la répression
avec encore plus de morts parce que là
on parle de 50 morts on est officiel
il y a d'autres chiffres circulent qui
sont beaucoup plus alarmistes on parle
aussi de plusieurs centaines de blessés
on parle de presque 2000 personnes
arrêtées ont tous ces chiffres peut-être
sont inexacts mais disons le simple fait
qu'ils existent manifestent une peur de
la société tchadienne il faut d'abord
rassurer cette société sur le fait qu'il
est possible de vivre ensemble et
tchadiens ont démontré à de multiples
occasions c'est vraiment un message
politique qui doit être fait qui et je
suis
pas totalement surpris mais disons peiné
en tout cas que le gouvernement actuel
qui comprend des
[Musique]
avoir recours à un possible éventuel
soutien international ou à l'appui des
organisations de droits de l'homme pour
aller au-delà merci pour leur Marchal
vous restez avec nous nous sommes en
ligne avec notre correspondant Mamadou
et Jim tebaye qui m'a donc nous
expliquer bonjour Mamadou comment s'est
déroulé cette première prise de parole
du président depuis donc les événements
de jeudi dernier ce fameux Jeudi Noir
bonsoir
bonsoir donc
ce jour tragique alors qu'on laisse
ensemble de ce qui qui constitue son
discours il faudra retenir la
déclaration des 7 jours de deuil mais
aussi le fait qu'il est revenu sur les
causes selon lui de cette journée
dramatique il a qu'on appelle
accusé les auteurs qu'il a désigné à
savoir le parti le transformateur et les
mouvements ou la coalition
dans le parti de consommateurs et la
correction il est revenu en disant dans
ces
mots que je répète ce qui s'est passé
témoigne de la volonté manifeste de
déclencher une guerre civile donc la
réponse
à la à cette insurrection et la cause de
cette de ce résultat dramatique
merci beaucoup Mamadou pour votre
correspondance ce soir et merci encore
Roland Marchal d'être venu ce soir sur
notre plateau à bientôt c'était sa
première prise de parole on l'a dit on
va continuer avec ce forum international
de Dakar sur la paix et la sécurité il
s'est ouvert aujourd'hui dans la
capitale sénégalaise un rendez-vous
annuel pour aborder les problématiques
sécurité du continent africain le
président Macky Sall en a profité pour
lancer un plaidoyer plaidoyer pour la
réforme du Conseil de sécurité des
Nations unies inefficaces selon lui pour
la pacification de l'Afrique les détails
c'est avec elimann Daho notre
correspondant dans le pays
cette huitième édition du Forum
international de Dakar sur la paix et la
sécurité a vu la participation à mars
des pays lisophone notamment l'Angola
représenté par son président jouant
Lorenzo mais également le président du
Cap-Vert et le vice 1er ministre de la
Guinée-Bissau le forum est également vu
la participation de quinzaine de
ministres des Affaires étrangères venus
des quatre coins du monde l'occasion
pour le Sénégal pays stable dans un
Sahel marqué par des remous et des
crises sécuritaires de d'explorer des
solutions pour une pacification de
l'Afrique une pacification qui passe
selon le président Macky Sall à part la
réforme du Conseil de sécurité je vous
propose d'écouter le président
sénégalais qui en même temps président
en exercice de l'Union africaine et face
au terrorisme
les opérations classiques de paix des
Nations Unies ont montré leur limite ce
forum au fil des ans a eu à prouver
qu'il est temps de changer la doctrine
le multilatéralisme doit servir les
intérêts de tous
autrement il continuera de susciter la
méfiance des gens la défiance des autres
le forum également l'occasion pour des
experts en sécurité venu d'horizon
divers de réfléchir sur le thème de
cette année à l'Afrique face au choc
exogènes les défis de stabilité et de
souveraineté
il a été nommé vendredi dernier par les
militaires au pouvoir Apollinaire
joaquimaine de tembella a pris ses
fonctions de Premier ministre du Burkina
Faso ancien avocat il s'était montré
très critique en vain en vert l'ancienne
homme fort du pays j'ai nommé le
lieutenant-colonel Sanda Hogo danyba et
vincée vous le savez par les puchistes
seulement 8 mois après son propre coup
d'état bangality
74 ans Apollinaire du Hakim qu'il aime
de tambella est avocat de professions et
assez connu des médias au Burkina Faso
il a fait ses études universitaires en
France Joachim et docteur d'État en
droit il est également diplômé il est
également diplômé de langue en
civilisation anglaise et américaine
d'ailleurs il est membre de
l'Association américaine des sciences
politiques il enseigne dans plusieurs
universités notamment en France au
Canada et ici au Burkina Faso mais
aujourd'hui c'est toute une autre
fonction qui s'apprête à exercer et pour
le journaliste politique Dieudonné
zumbrana le tout nouveau Premier
ministre devrait faire preuve de
pragmatisme le Premier ministre doit
éviter bon l'éternel piège qui est le
copinage dans le froid des hommes
et il faut que il fasse un bon
management efficient ensuite il est
centralis il n'en fait pas mystère et il
faut qu'il évite le syncarisme et désuet
et des incarnés Sankara a vécu à 35 nous
sommes en 2022 il y avait 7 millions en
1987 nous sommes de sur 22 millions donc
il faudra qu'il fasse une bonne
adéquation entre les idéaux sanguins et
les réalités actuelles la nomination de
son équipe gouvernementale est attendue
dans les 48 heures un gouvernement dont
le nombre de ministres ne devrait pas
excéder 25 selon la charte de la
transition
Apollinaire Joachim qui l'aime de
tambella cheveux former un gouvernement
de reconquête de la souveraineté
intégrale de son pays selon ses premiers
mots à la presse
et j'ajoute ce soir que le Burkina Faso
a été le théâtre du nouvel attaque cela
se passe à Djibo dans le Nord ville sous
blocus djihadiste bilan dit soldatés et
50 blessés annonce aujourd'hui de
l'armée autre attaque meurtrière cette
fois au Niger au moins deux policiers
ont été tués samedi déjà on civil avait
été à massacrer dans la région de
tilabéric c'est bien sûr un nouveau
revers pour les autorités alors que leur
était plutôt à l'Académie ces derniers
mois les précisions aniamées de notre
correspondant à rôle de Girard
nous avons appris qu'une nouvelle
attaque dans la journée à viser le poste
de police de Tamou commune rurale située
près de la frontière avec le Burkina
Faso selon plusieurs sources sécurité
c'est au moins deux policiers qui ont
perdu la vie lors de cette attaque alors
même que les autorités nigériennes n'ont
pour l'instant pas donné de bilan
officiel dimanche déjà deux soldats de
la Garde aide nationale du Niger ont été
tués lors d'une attaque près du site
aurifère de manga toujours dans la
région de tilaberry deux agressions
contre les forces armées nigériennes qui
interviennent après que samedi 11 civils
étaient exécutés dans le nord de la
région de Tillabéri près du village
abandonné de Ziggy Zeno dans les
départements cette fois-ci de banni
Bangou dans une zone frontalière du Mali
la région de tilaberry et la plus
impactée par les activités des groupes
armés à travers le Niger et malgré une
période de relative à calmer ces
derniers mois la dégradation de
situation sécurité au Mali et au Burkina
Faso les deux États qui sont frontaliers
de cette région de tilaberry risque de
replonger l'Ouest nigérien dans un
moment extrêmement difficile
le Niger oula situation sécurité se
dégrade nettement à sa frontière avec le
Mali une région où sont originaire des
milliers de déplacés que Niamey espère
pouvoir envoyer chez eux un jour des
Nigériens très sceptiques vous allez le
voir lorsque l'on parle de paix durable
reportage signé à rôle de girafe vous
venez de l'entendre
village nigérien a environ 100 km de la
frontière avec le Mali l'État islamique
et les groupes affiliés Al-Qaïda sème la
terreur à quelques encablures de la
frontière avec le Niger Karim wasan est
originaire de la localité de Tin garage
il a fui la violence terroristique il y
a 3 ans aujourd'hui il représente la
communauté des déplacés de tandis que
Wendy
au nom de Dieu il continue toujours à
attaquer il y a toujours l'insécurité
autour de mon village ça ne va pas ça ne
va pas du tout
pour l'instant on ne sait pas encore ce
que l'arrivée de nouveaux partenaires au
Niger va apporter mais lorsque les
choses se calment on l'apprend jusqu'à
présent tu ne peux pas aller dans la
zone sans protection
c'est maintenant qu'il faut cultiver
pour éviter une nouvelle année de crise
alimentaire le gouvernement a affiché sa
volonté de réinstaller plusieurs
communautés de déplacer dans leur
localité d'origine dans ce but précis
mais pour une large partie de ces
nigériens qui ont fui les massacres la
paix dans leur département n'est pas
encore acquise on nous propose de
rentrer chez nous mais aujourd'hui nous
ne sommes pas suffisamment rassurés
locales sont les premières à accueillir
les flux de déplacés en termes le risque
d'agression est plus ou moins élevé en
fonction de la localisation des villages
proche ou éloigné de la frontière mais
la crainte du nouvel intensification des
attaques et la même pour toute la région
parce que le problème même est venu du
Mali depuis le début depuis en 2012 vous
savez le problème de terrorisme là c'est
pas seulement
l'aspect militaire qu'il faut voir il
faut il faut voir aussi l'aspect
développement
et l'aspect développement et cohésion
sociale
comme beaucoup insanalidou regrette la
dégradation des relations entre le Mali
et le Niger le gouvernement nigérien et
la gente militaire malienne son
diamétralement opposés sur la question
de la coopération avec les armées
étrangères contre le terrorisme
voilà donc pour ce document de notre
correspondance et la fin de ce journal
de l'Afrique on se retrouve dans moins
d'une heure pour le prochain je vous dis
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]